70 the professional does not give his  power away to others  the dictionary defines icon as an  article  a relic say that once belonged to a  saint or a holy man  that serves as an object of worship  a person can be an icon  when we make someone into an icon we  give away our power  we say to ourselves unconsciously this  person possesses qualities i wish i  possessed  therefore i will worship this person in  the hope that that quality will wear off  on me  or i will acquire that quality by virtue  of my proximity  to this mentor sensei lover teacher hero  in my experience when we project  equality or virtue onto another human  being  we ourselves almost always already  possess  that quality but we're afraid to embrace  and to live that truth the amateur is an  acolyte  a groupie the professional may seek  instruction or wisdom  from one who is further along in mastery  than he  but he does so without surrendering his  self-sovereignty